werden wir jemals in der lage sein dinge
direkt mit unserem gehirn zu steuern
ja und es ist bereits realität
beeindruckende bilder wie ein flugzeug
nur mit gedanken gesteuert wird jetzt
den krieg zum zeichentrick
es ist wie in einem science fiction
stadt mit einem steuerknüppel ist es mit
dieser haube möglich flugzeuge nur mit
gedanken zu steuern
der steuerknüppel ist gar nicht mehr
nötig allein die hirnströme steuern das
flugzeug hier im flugsimulator
durch das direkte feedback also dadurch
dass die piloten sofort sehen was ihre
gedanken bewirken ist die steuerung
bereits mit relativ großer präzision
möglich ein test pilot flog nahezu alle
vorgegebenen routen mit einer abweichung
von maximal 10 grad ab auch die landung
gelang bereits so dass das flugzeug auch
in der realität problemlos aufgesetzt
hätte aber was passiert eigentlich bei
dieser technik können jetzt schon mit
hilfe von elektroenzephalografie
elektroden also dem berühmten eeg es
gedanken gelesen werden
normalerweise werden diese elektroden
eingesetzt um in der forschung
aktivitäten in bestimmten hirnregionen
zu messen oder auch in der medizin um
störungen im gehirn aufzuspüren
aber dass ein gedanke damit
entschlüsselt werden könnte sehr war das
undenkbar und jetzt scheint es aber zu
gehen zumindest rechts und links können
damit als befehle gemessen werden
allerdings so beruhigen die forscher
wirkliche gedanken können so nicht
gelesen werden
der algorithmus der an der technischen
universität münchen entwickelt wurde ist
allerdings so ausgefeilt dass er die
beiden anweisungen rechts und links aus
den hirnen signalen auslesen kann
hier oben links im bild ist zu erkennen
wie stark die befehle im gehirn gegeben
werden und dann zur steuerung verwendet
werden
noch ist die genauigkeit zwar schon
beachtlich aber noch nicht so hoch wie
bei einem steuerknüppel
das liegt auch daran dass die
rückkopplung der kräfte die an einem
steuerknüppel anliegen fehlt es fehlt
ein gegendruck wir an der steuerung
eines flugzeugs zu spüren ist
trotzdem sind die perspektiven dieser
technik unglaublich die forscher sehen
eine deutliche vereinfachung des
friedens die arbeitsbelastung für
piloten würde sinken und fliegen
könnte sicherer werden nicht zuletzt
könnten so mehr menschen flugzeuge
stellen und die ausbildung könnte
vereinfacht werden weiter gedacht sind
die konsequenzen aber noch viel
umfassender flugzeuge brauchen keine
steuerknüppel autos keine lenkräder mehr
und so weiter und so fort wenn wir in
der lage wären unsere umgebung mit
gedanken zu steuern wird sich alles
dramatisch verändern griffe schalter
knöpfe alles würde verschwinden
und wenn dann noch die anzeigen zum
beispiel von temperaturen
geschwindigkeiten und so weiter in eine
google brille oder kontaktlinsen wandern
dann stehen wir vor einer umfassenden
verwandlung der wirklichkeit denn dann
wird die realität erst durch die
zusätzliche virtuelle realität die
argumente trelle tea komplett erst wenn
ich im auto die geschwindigkeit in
google glas sehe kann ich jetzt mit
meinen gedanken steuern und auch meine
gedanken gehören dann zu dieser realität
sie werden unmittelbar wirklichkeit wenn
ich dem autor befehle zum beispiel
schneller zu fahren
wow das ist wirklich science fiction was
meint ihr wird sich unsere realität so
dramatisch verändern diskutiertes in den
kommentaren
das letzte mal hier bei pixum auch
unbedingt ansehen das tal der ufos noch
ungeklärte licht phänomen in einem
norwegischen tal die linkswähler video
beschreibung und wer gar nicht verpassen
will der sollte sich die app runterladen
da gibt es täglich wissenschafts news
alle videos und noch vieles mehr dafür
da klicken und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran